>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> It's September 20, 2017.
I'm Jennifer Cutting.
I'm a Folk Life Specialist in
the American Folk Life Center,
and I'm here with Cathy
Fink and Marcy Marxer,
who have just participated
in the Take the Archive
Challenge Concert
in our Homegrown Concert Series.
Cathy and Marcy, thank you for
taking the Archive Challenge.
>> Thank you, Jennifer.
This is wonderful.
>> You sounded wonderful on
the stuff that you picked,
and what was interesting to
me is that some of the folks
in the Archive Challenge
came into the Reading Room
to select their material, and
some of you selected it online,
and you guys didn't come
into the Reading Room,
but found great stuff online.
And I wondered you know, were
there any particular challenges
about finding it online
as opposed to coming
into the Reading Room?
>> They are definitely
different experiences,
but because we were,
from the time we heard
about the challenge to today,
we were traveling so much,
that we knew we weren't going to
have the time to come in and sit
and do that, away from
travels and things like that.
And it was such an incredible
experience, to have the luxury
of listening on the
road through the magic
of the archives on the internet.
And in some ways, it
probably offered us different
opportunities than doing
this live and in person.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Simply because you can
just keep scrolling through
and honestly, I would say
that I probably got lost
in about 12 hours of listening.
>> Wow! That's amazing
amount of listening.
>> It's an amazing
amount of listening,
and some of it was pieces
I was familiar with.
A lot of it were pieces
I wasn't familiar with.
I probably earmarked 10
pieces for us to consider
that we didn't do, but that
are now on our list of oh,
there's a song I'd
like to do sometime.
>> Oh great, maybe there's
an album in it [chuckles].
>> That would be great.
>> There could very well.
I mean, there could be
so many albums in it.
And particularly of things that
are not terribly well-known,
or not known at all, you know?
And I think that's
one of the beauties
that there is this archive of
common ground, and obscurities.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And--
>> Hidden gems.
>> Hidden gems, you know?
They're little diamonds
in the sand.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> It was a great experience
to do that listening,
and by example, we played a
medley of fiddle tunes collected
by Alan Jabbour, the founder of
the American Folk Life Center,
of him and his wife Karen,
collecting fiddle tunes
from a southern Virginia
fiddler named Henry Reed.
And both of the tunes that we
picked are tunes that we knew.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> But to listen in detail
exactly how Henry Reed played
them, and bring that
back, 30 to 40 years
after learning those tunes.
>> Wow!
>> It's a really
nice experience.
And I have to say that it gave
me a renewed huge appreciation,
not only for Alan Jabbour's
work filtered out to us all
through the people he hung
with in Chappell Hill, Durham,
North Carolina, starting a band
called the Hollow Rock String
Band, touring and
performing with a bunch
of different string
bands, and recording some
of those tunes that, you
know, 30 or 40 years ago,
everybody was learning from
those second-hand recordings.
>> Yeah.
>> And at the time, no
internet, you'd be lucky
to hear a first-hand recording.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, we're lucky that we can
hear them either on the internet
or a beautiful visit here.
>> Well thank you for being so
eloquent about that experience.
It's a great case
for us continuing
to put collections online.
>> I can't beg you
enough [laughter]
to continue putting them online.
>> And the archives is magic,
though, I mean, there's so much
in there, you can
sit down and listen
to the original recordings
in the Library of Congress,
in the Folk Archives,
and it is unbelievable.
But one of the things the
internet does is let other
people experience some
of that magic, you know?
>> Right.
>> There's nothing
like listening
to the original recordings.
Absolutely nothing.
But at least there's
a way into that music.
>> And for busy musicians
on the road.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Like you guys.
>> Absolutely, and I
feel like, you know,
knowing that Sam Gleaves
was going to be here
and accompanying us, Sam
lives in Berea, Kentucky,
he had become good friends with
Jean Ritchey and her family,
and we worked with Jean many
times over the last 40 years
or so, accompanied her at some
festivals, been to, you know,
parties and Suarez, and jam
sessions and all of that,
and so we knew that we wanted
to do something of Jean's.
We also knew that we didn't
want to do something of hers
that was well-known,
or had been done a lot.
We wanted to dig in there.
And so there is that
short little song.
If I Were a Blackbird.
Which she learned from
someone in Ireland.
But it was while she was
on a Fulbright Scholarship,
researching the connections
between Appalachian music
and British Isles music.
And so we were right at the
corner of the two places
in her life at that time, and--
>> I didn't know the background.
>> That was, to me, very
influential and then add to that
that Sam had also spent
a lot of time with Jean,
we also felt it important to
also keep this very personal,
and because Alan and a lot of
his musical buddies were mentors
of ours, and as was Jean, as
well as friends, we just sort
of felt like, oh,
we get to learn,
we get to honor these
people at the same time,
we hear something new, and I
guarantee you, we'll be back
in those archives
on the road a lot.
>> Great, great to hear.
Great to hear.
Well, when I went back to
re-listen to those tunes
that you chose, I was struck
by how possibly challenging
it could be, to, you know,
for example, with the tune
Granny, it seemed to my ear
to have an extra beat at the end
of the A music, and I thought,
well are they going to
even it out, are they going
to put the extra beat in there?
And it just flowed,
the way you did it.
It was--
>> And I think that Henry
Reed was not always consistent
in where that extra beat might
happen, or might not happen.
And I know that he played
for a lot of dances.
He also played banjo and
harmonica, and my guess is
that he knew enough
in a dance not
to throw the extra
beat in [laughter].
>> When there were
dancers dancing, right.
I had mentioned before to you
that one of those tunes turned
up on a Flying Fish
album, and I think it was--
>> Shoes and Stockings.
>> Shoes and Stockings
turned up on Sandy's Fancy?
>> Right.
>> On the Flying
Fish label in 81,
but you said you were
playing it before that.
>> Well I learned the tune in
the late 70s, from Irene Herman,
who was a member of
the Harmony Sisters
with Alice Gerard
and Jeannie McCleary.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And Irene was hanging
out at Alice's house,
and I was down the street
at Helen Schnare's house,
in Kensington, Maryland,
Garrett Park area.
And I think Irene had probably
learned the tune from Alan.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> So that was my first
exposure to that tune.
And then of course Alan
recorded it with Sandy Bradley,
and it was re-released
as a double album,
I think with the Hollow Rock
String Band and Sandy's Fancy.
It was re-released as one CD.
>> Mm-hmm, okay.
>> And that gets a fair
amount of play in our car
on the road, actually.
>> Oh great!
>> Love those tunes,
and love hearing them,
love hearing Alan play them.
Brings back a lot of memories
to hear Sandy accompany him.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know,
it's a great way
of just keeping this
stuff alive.
I mean, the music, the music
exists, but the music is part
of the stories, and with each of
these tunes, Marcy has a story,
I have a story, Sam has a story.
Alan has a story.
Henny Reed has a story.
Then all these stories swirl
around each other,
and what do you know?
Next thing is Sam's whole
generation 40 years younger
than us.
They embrace this, they have
stories, and it keeps on going.
It morphs.
As it should.
You know, Sam Gleaves is
an amazing songwriter,
but right in the heart center
of the kind of tradition
that Jean Ritchey
wrote songs in.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And to me, that's where
we gather our strength
from the people before us.
>> That's beautifully
put, beautifully put,
and today Alan Jabbour's
tunes that he collected,
as played by you, have come
home, and Jean Ritchey's song,
that's in our collection,
has come home.
With that particular song,
If I Were a Blackbird,
it was sung unaccompanied, and
when I listen to what you did
with it, adding penny
whistle, I was not able to get
out into the audience
during the concert,
so I couldn't tell were you
playing in standard tuning
or in alternate tuning?
>> No, I actually played
guitar in a banjo tuning.
>> Oh, that's interesting!
>> And on this song, we
played around with about six
or seven different
arrangement possibilities.
>> Uh huh.
>> I talked about playing it
on the dulcimer, since Jean was
such a beautiful dulcimer
player, and I actually--
dulcimer was my third
instrument.
Piano first, guitar
second, dulcimer third.
And I thought about that,
and we loved the song
so much we realized
that we were going
to want to be performing it.
Outside of this concert,
we're doing a lot
of shows together with Sam.
>> That's great news to us!
>> And so I thought, you
know, I love the dulcimer,
but we're not going to
be taking it on the road.
Where can I get the drones,
and sort of that, again,
that cross-section
between where Appalachian
and British Isles
music and vibes meet.
And so I knew it was going to
be an open tuning on the guitar,
and I also thought, you
know, I could put this
in a banjo modal tuning.
>> Ah!
>> So that's what I did.
I put my guitar in
banjo modal tuning.
>> Uh huh.
>> And it gave me all
the drones that I wanted,
which is what the
dulcimer would give us.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Then Sam added some of that,
along with the melody
on the fiddle.
>> And Marcy captured some
of that Irish ornamentation.
>> Exactly.
>> And her beautiful vocal.
>> In her vocal.
>> And the penny whistle.
>> And penny whistle.
And it turned, you know,
I think the thing is,
it's a great example of
a tiny little melody,
I mean Jean's recording
is very short.
>> It is short.
>> It's a tiny little melody,
but it's such a beautiful
melody.
>> And it's a great story.
>> And you want to hear
it over and over again.
You don't tire of it.
And so we felt like, well if we
introduce it with the fiddle,
and then some of
the story comes out,
and then a little more story and
the fiddle and the penny whistle
that we could more
thoroughly tell this story.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And it just felt like what
we wanted to be doing with it.
And my guess, we're about
to make a recording,
so this may end up on it.
>> That's wonderful.
So the arrangement
that you put together
for today's archive
challenge concert will go
on to have a life.
>> Absolutely.
>> And all goes around again.
So.
>> Well it does, and it
goes around in another way,
I mean Cathy touched on this,
but to us, not only to know
that their music is here, and
it's always available to anybody
who wants to hear
it is remarkable,
but these are people
who were our friends.
You know? We could have gone
another way, but with Alan,
and Jean, they're people
we knew our entire careers,
until they passed,
which was recent.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And with Alan, we spent
years playing at folk festivals
and cliff top jam festivals
with him and Mike Seger,
and with Jean, you
know, we just loved her.
And we got hired years ago to
play a festival that she was at,
the Golden Link in Rochester.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And I was really happy
because I could get a whole hour
of Jean Ritchey, and she
was going to play solo.
This was so long ago, I can't
remember how long it was,
but then she asked us to play
with her, and we thought,
oh yeah, that's nice too.
And she said, "Well I want it
to be just like my records,"
so we ran to the CD
table, bought records,
and went to the car, and learned
the arrangements on the records
as fast as we could,
and hoped for the best.
>> Wow.
>> But then we had a
repertoire with Jean,
you know, we knew her stuff.
>> About how much of it was
it a whole, you know, hour?
>> Oh it was an hour.
>> Uh huh.
>> Yeah, it was an hour,
off three different CDs,
and she gave us a list of songs.
>> Wow.
>> So that was great, but then
to see that, this is available
to people, anybody
who wants to hear it,
young people doing research,
older people doing research,
people want to delve
into the music further.
It's just such a great resource.
Thank you for your work--
>> I want to say too--
>> It's really remarkable.
>> Oh, thank you
for thanking us.
>> In listening to Jean's
recording that Alan Lomax made,
in this particular recording,
was made in his apartment
in Greenwich Village.
>> Exactly.
>> Third Street, 1949.
>> June 2nd, 1949.
So neither of us was around yet.
But when you listen to
her sing, the purity,
and clarity of her
voice is so there.
And Jean had that remained
part of her singing.
It was, you know, I want
to say unadulterated.
It was such a pure,
Appalachian soprano.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> And just beautiful to hear
the young Jean Ritchey sing,
and make that connection
to various other stages
in her career, where
we got to hear her.
>> Mm-hmm.
You heard her at many
stages of the life cycle.
>> Absolutely.
Absolutely.
>> Well it's wonderful to
know that you went back so far
with her, that you had
this connection with her,
and with Alan Jabbour,
and as I say,
it's all come home
today with this concert.
And we very much appreciate
both of you coming,
and sharing your arrangements
of these songs and tunes,
and taking the Archive
Challenge.
Thank you Cathy and Marcy.
>> Thank you.
>> Thanks for inviting us, this
was-- a pleasure and a treat.
>> It was a blast.
>> It was great.
>> Thank you.
>> September 20th, 2017,
I'm Jennifer Cutting,
a folk life specialist in the
American Folk Life Center,
and I'm here with Klezmer
genius, Seth Kibel.
We've just concluded the Archive
Challenge sampler concert.
That took place in the
Coolidge Auditorium,
in which musicians were invited
to identify field recordings
that they could fall
in love with,
and put their own
creative stamp on,
and play for a very
appreciative audience,
and they were appreciative
today.
>> Oh yeah.
>> You played a medley of tunes
from the Ruth Rubin Collection,
from a musician called Barish
[assumed spelling] Cats.
Can you tell me a little
bit about Barish Katz?
>> Sure, well Barish Katz
was a fiddler, violinist.
He also worked as a Bodkin
in the old country, now,
Bodkin was kind of like--
imagine a cross between a
ringmaster for a circus,
and a wedding planner
for a Jewish wedding.
You know, Jewish weddings in the
old country were very confusing
and complicated affairs.
They, you know, took place for
several days, often as long
as a week, involving
the entire community.
There was no such thing as
a guest list, and took place
in various locations, indoors
and outdoors throughout
the Stettler Village.
So the Bodkin was
responsible for, you know,
making sure everyone did what
they were supposed to do,
and were where they
were supposed to be
at the right time, and
organizing the sequence
of events, and making sure
everyone did what they're
supposed to do at
the right time,
but also introducing people,
and just generally making sure
the guests had a good time.
Again, kind of an emcee,
ringmaster sort of person.
And yeah, Barish Katz did
that in the old country,
and apparently he came from
a long line of Bodkins,
and Ruth Rubin, well,
let me back up,
the Ruth Rubin Archive
is a legendary archive
in Jewish music, I mean, it
has just been a treasure trove
of material, mostly
from the Ashkenazi,
eastern European
Jewish tradition.
Now, a vast majority
of the countless hours
Ruth Rubin recorded is
of vocal music.
She traveled all over the world,
throughout New York, Israel,
all over, and getting people
to sing these songs for her.
Now, I'm not a vocalist,
so I was very intrigued
by the Ruth Rubin Archives,
and enjoyed listening to stuff.
But I found this
tape by this fiddler,
I thought okay this is something
I can, like, directly tackle.
So Barish Katz was originally
from Galatia, which is, well,
I guess it's today part of
present-day Poland and Ukraine.
And he played for Ruth Rubin
in 1947, all these songs
that he said he learned from
his uncle in the old country,
in the town where they grew
up, which is called Glena,
and it was great to listen to.
Because there were all these
little snippets, you know,
20 seconds, 30 seconds, 45
seconds, just tune after tune
after tune, and like
so much of this music,
everything sounded
vaguely familiar to me,
but nothing was actually
something I'd heard before,
so it was all like,
you know, new melodies,
and new repertoire, for
me, which was so much fun
to sink my teeth into.
>> And you did a great
job of arranging them
into two separate medleys.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> How did you decide which
tunes to put in which medley?
>> Yeah, you know, what I
did is first I listened a lot
to the recordings after you guys
so kindly digitized them for me,
and I picked a whole bunch of
melodic snippets that I liked,
that I just, in and
of themselves, again,
unaccompanied violin, and
then I transcribed those,
so then you know, midway
through this process,
I had all these transcriptions,
of all these little
different melodic fragments,
or short excerpts, and
then I began to think,
okay how can I group
these together in ways
that make various, at least
some semblance of sense,
and I tried to balance
it, because what I wanted
to do was I wanted
to make sure some
of the melodies were presented
in a more traditional light,
perhaps closer to the way
Barish Katz himself might have
performed them in an ensemble,
and then some of them I wanted
to put my own spin on them,
partially because I love
to keep it a, you know,
living, breathing tradition,
and partly because
it's just more fun,
it's kind of self-indulgent.
So I just found, I experimented
on my own, playing them
in different combinations, and
what if I put this one here,
and this one there, you
know, it almost seems kind
of mathematical, I had
numbered them all, so I'd like--
okay, what if I go from
7 to 9 to 3, and then,
okay that doesn't work,
how about 7, 9, 2!
You know, and I eventually
came up with these two melodies
that seemed to flow
pretty naturally.
>> Thanks for describing
your process,
which I was wondering about,
as I heard your medleys,
which so nicely moved
from different tempos
to different tonalities,
speaking of tonalities,
the field recordings
that you were working
with were just unaccompanied
melodies.
>> Right.
>> And yet you came with
a pianist, Sean Lane,
who was playing chords
with these melodies.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, did you decide on what
chords were going to be played
with the melodies, or did
Sean, or was it a combination?
>> It was mostly me.
I sat down and I'm
a bad pianist, and--
>> And a good arranger
[laughter].
>> Yes, yes, thank you,
and I sat down and worked
out harmonizations for all
these things, and again,
different melodies I took
different approaches to.
Some I said okay what-- a lot
of the melody is pretty
obvious what the original
harmonies were--
>> Right.
>> Like, let me go with what
it probably was, you know,
and then there are
some other melodies,
like the waltz we ended with,
where I'm like okay, no,
I'm not going to go with what
was probably the original
harmonies, I'm going to probably
put some jazz substitutions
and some chords that probably
would have made Barish Katz keel
over [laughter], you
know, I have no idea.
>> I noticed that you
started with a straight waltz,
and went into a jazz waltz.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And that was fun.
>> Yeah.
>> And on one of the tunes,
I noticed you used some
kind of Latino rhythm.
>> Yeah, yeah, we used that
kind of Montuno beat, uh,
kind of a Latin beat,
which fit remarkably well.
>> It did.
>> Under what was originally
probably a traditional Klezmer
freilach or bulgur, in fact,
we were talking, we might,
at least that part,
we might just play!
On gigs and no one--
>> Oh!
>> No one would even know,
no would even know
[overlapping speakers].
It worked shockingly well, so...
>> Uh huh.
>> So that was fun.
>> It was great.
And tell me about the
process of incorporating Sean
into your arrangement?
>> Well, Sean and I
have worked together
for years and years and years.
And the nice thing about
working with a musician
who you are very good friends
with and work very well with is
that you don't really have
to worry about their ego.
So we were able to rehearse
and I could, you know,
I could easily say I don't
like what you just did,
and I don't have to worry
about him taking it personally.
He knows I respect him
and like his musicianship.
So it made it very
easy to kind of get him
to do what I was
hearing in my head.
You know? Because we were
so used to working together,
I was able to say okay,
that I liked, or you know,
change this feel, or
do something here.
And he is someone
who originally,
well he has classical training,
but is a very accomplished
jazz pianist.
But then through me has done
a fair amount of Jewish music
as well, so he's got some
background in that as well,
and we tried to bring
all of that
into the arrangements we did.
>> Have you ever tackled
field recordings before,
or is this your first
time using them?
>> This is certainly the
first time I've done this
in any serious degree,
I mean, this was kind
of a new experience for me.
It was so much fun coming into
the archives, and just listening
to his stuff, and you
know, listening to some
of these field recordings,
it almost feels
like the closest
thing I will ever come
to an actual time machine.
You know, you feel almost
voyeuristic, I mean,
it's one thing when
you're listening
to a commercial recording,
even one that is made,
you know, 80, 90 years ago.
You know the musicians being
listened to are expecting,
or at least hoping that
other people will listen
to that music.
This is different.
This is the strange woman comes
into this guy's apartment,
you know, and says play me some
songs, play into this machine,
you know, even though it
was 1947, I've got to think
that would have been
even beyond,
almost beyond his comprehension.
I don't want to say that in too
insulting a way, but just like,
hard to fathom that those
melodies he was playing
in that moment, in 1947 would
be reinterpreted some 60--
is my math right?
Sixty years later!
No, 70! Seventy years later,
in the Library of Congress.
I mean, that, when
I think about that,
that almost gives
me goose pimples.
Like I say, I feel kind
of voyeuristic, you know,
that's a little window in time.
So anyway, I totally
enjoyed the process.
It was a real thrill.
>> Well, we totally enjoyed
having you [chuckling]
and I just want to
thank you, Seth Kibel,
and I want to thank your
accompanist, Sean Lane,
for taking the Archive
Challenge.
>> Yes, thank you!
>> September 20, 2017,
and I'm Jennifer Cutting,
Folk Life Specialist, with
the American Folk Life Center,
here at the Library of Congress.
We are here with Brazilian
musician, Cissa Paz,
who has just performed in
our Homegrown Concert Series,
Archive Challenge Concert.
And I'm happy to be
talking to Cissa now,
about how she chose the field
recordings that she chose,
and what the process of
arranging them was like.
So first, I'll ask you, of
the Brazilian collections
that I recommended to
you, how did you hone
in on the discotheque
collection?
>> Well I listened to all of it.
And all of it was so rich and
exciting, and it was really hard
to choose one, I mean two,
I had to choose two
pieces, which was nice.
But I knew that I wanted to work
with something that was related
to the African and the Indian
influence, so that's kind
of what I was looking
for, and finding things
that I could relate
to from my background,
as well as from my
musical experience.
So it wasn't too bad, once I
started listening to everything,
and I found some favorite ones,
and I kind of said, okay, these,
I think I'm going to do these,
and then I was still like, oh,
but maybe I want to do this
one too [chuckling], you know?
It was hard, a hard decision.
Do you want me to speak
specifically on each one?
>> Yeah, the two that you chose
were [foreign words spoken],
and [foreign words spoken].
>> Yeah. So [foreign
words spoken],
I thought it was interesting
because Mina [assumed spelling]
actually means a person
who comes from the area of
what is Benin right now?
>> Okay.
>> And when I did, you
know, my ancestry map,
whatever it's called--
>> The DNA testing?
>> Yeah, yeah, I saw that's
where my heritage
is from, from Benin.
>> Oh.
>> So of course,
instantly I was like,
oh this is cool,
I want to do this.
Makes sense, it's
like connected.
>> That's a very
personal connection.
>> Yeah, it was.
It was personal, and I thought
it was a beautiful song,
and I thought I could
do something, you know,
all these songs are simple,
so it's not like I didn't do
anything very complex with them,
I just found a few chords that
worked together with the melody
and I kind of put it together
that way and it worked.
I liked it anyway, I
thought it was nice.
Then I added some more
melodies, and it was cool.
>> And you actually got people
in the Coolidge Auditorium
up to dance, that
is, you will go
down in history for
that [laughter].
That alone.
>> That's great.
It was fun.
>> So the field recordings
that you chose, when I listened
to them, I thought what's
interesting is first of all,
they're not accompanied with
anything but percussion,
so you had to add
chords to them.
Also with [foreign word spoken],
it was like this rapid fire,
almost like machine gun
rapid fire of quick words--
>> Yeah.
>> And I wondered how you
were going to deal with that.
Did you slow it down a little?
>> Not really.
I mean, I think it
was pretty fast.
And it's like, there
is a specific style
in Brazilian music, where
we speak and in Africa, too,
if you notice, it's
almost spoken,
it's almost like a precursor
to hip hop or something,
where you speak really
fast, but you're singing,
and you're going [makes noise].
>> And it's almost percussive.
>> Yeah. It's percussive,
and it's-- but it's melodic,
and it kind of all blends and
works together, but it is harder
to work with than if you're just
working with a smooth melody.
So that's why I added some.
I added a little bit of a hook
in the beginning and in the end,
and I just-- to make it a little
bit more chill and melodic,
but also work with
the dance vibe,
because I really wanted
people to, at least dance
in their seats, and
some of them--
>> Uh huh!
>> Ended up standing
up and dancing--
>> Got up.
They did.
>> Which was really good, yeah.
So it worked out.
Mm-hmm.
>> And I think on the
[foreign words spoken],
was it kind of a layered vocal,
where in the field recording the
main singer would sing a little
bit, and then another
singer would come in,
kind of over that.
And sing a little bit, and I
wondered how you were going
to handle doing that
as a soloist,
when there were actually more
singers on the field recording?
>> Yeah, so that style is very
common across Africa and Brazil,
which is the call and response,
and that's basically
what she was doing.
And I just treated it more
like a song, and I repeated it,
and I kind of did the call
and response myself, I called
and I responded by myself.
And it worked, then
I tried to change,
change the harmony a little
bit, so that it would sound
like some layers on there, even
though it's just one voice.
>> What was it like, trying
to transcribe the words
to [foreign word spoken] and
[foreign word spoken] material,
that might not be in
your spoken vocabulary?
>> Yeah, you know,
what's interesting is
that I don't know
what the words say,
and there was no translation in
the materials that I had, so I--
but at the same time, when I
was listening and reading it,
I could feel a familiarity
with the sounds,
because I am familiar with a lot
of the [foreign word
spoken] music,
the [foreign word spoken]
tradition and the Congo,
and what they call the
[foreign word spoken] tradition
in the north.
It's all in my blood already,
because I have been listening
to it since I was little,
even though I don't really know
exactly what they're saying,
but I do understand a
few words here and there,
and so it wasn't too difficult.
It was actually harder
to understand the
[foreign word spoken] song,
which was in Portuguese.
>> Uh huh.
Okay.
>> Only because he was
slurring his words,
and he had a very thick accent,
and the recording was
difficult to understand.
>> Yeah.
>> So I had to make
some of that up,
because I'm like I don't know
exactly what he's saying,
I'm kind of getting some words,
but I'm not getting
everything he's saying.
But the [foreign words spoken]
was shorter, and it was more--
it was easier to make
out what she was saying.
>> And what language
was that in?
>> I'm pretty sure that was
[foreign language spoken].
But I could be wrong,
I could be mistaken,
because I didn't find
information on that,
on the materials I had.
So.
>> So tell me about the process
of incorporating
Fernando into the work.
Once did you do the work first,
of deciding on the chords?
Deciding on the words, and then
did you bring Fernando in later?
>> Yeah, that's exactly right.
So Fernando is very
talented percussionist,
and he is very creative with the
instrumentation that he uses,
and the ideas that he has,
and actually we didn't get
a whole lot of time to work
on this, but I think we're
going to continue to work
on these songs in the
future, and he was talking
about maybe making, doing a
percussion arrangement to one
of these songs, and
maybe we will record it
in the future, who knows?
>> Oh that's wonderful news,
and make sure you tell us,
if you do, put it
on a recording,
because we will brag about you.
>> I will, yay [laughs].
>> So when did you
come to this country?
>> 1994.
>> Okay.
>> Long time ago.
>> And where were you born?
>> I was born in Belgium,
because my father
was working there,
so I was born there by chance.
I didn't get to have
Belgian citizenship,
but my Brazilian friends
make fun of me, they're like,
you're not a real Brazilian,
and I'm like, where am I from,
then [laughs], but I was
raised there from age 2,
and then I moved here
when I was like 17, 18.
>> You were raised
in Brazil from age 2?
>> Yeah.
>> And then you came
here when you were 18?
>> 18, 17, 18?
Yeah, and it was a really
difficult culture shock
when I first arrived, because
that age is just really
difficult to be moving when
you're just kind of discovering
who you are, and what you want
to be, and what your place is
in the world, and
then you're displaced
into a brand new culture,
brand new language, brand new--
I already spoke English,
but everything else
was really difficult
to understand, and
kind of adapt to.
It took me a little while.
Yeah. Now, I'm happy.
Now I like living here.
>> Great. Have you found a
large Brazilian community?
>> Yeah, huge, and I've always
been very, very connected
to the Brazilian community,
very in love with my culture,
and that was one of the things
that was hardest moving here,
was that I just really wanted
to participate in the culture,
and I wanted to make
sure I knew the dances,
and I knew the music,
and I knew the culture,
and it was just very,
very important to me.
So I've always remained
very connected to that.
And always traveled a lot,
back home, all the time.
I would take semesters
off from college,
and go back all the time.
So always connected.
>> And your usual
performing repertoire,
how would you characterize it?
>> I do a lot of...so, when I
do like, let's say a club gig,
for example, I will
do a lot of covers,
because I know that's
what people want to hear.
[Foreign word spoken] is
something that is very popular,
and it's similar
rhythm to the Coco,
which is the [foreign
word spoken] song.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> That we played, and
people loved to dance
and it's a very easy
dance, and just fun.
It's just fun.
And the name comes from when
in the northeast they would
welcome the military Americans
that would be there, working, to
the party by naming the parties
"For All," and right in
front of the party door,
it would say "for all,"
and it became "For All,
for all, for all [mumbling].
It became fo-ho [phonetic
spelling],
and that is kind of
how it came about.
And it's just something
that never dies.
In Brazil, there is a lot
of fashions that go through,
you know, oh now this
music is super popular,
[foreign word spoken] is
super popular right now,
then there was Lombado [phonetic
spelling], a long time ago then,
there's always something new.
But fo-ho, some of
these artistic,
what they call [foreign
word spoken] kind of music,
just stays with us, and that's
a beautiful thing that it does,
and fo-ho is one
of these things.
So I play a lot of-- some fo-ho,
and I play a lot of samba,
samba is one of the things that
are very close to my heart.
Samba is very, very,
very dear to me.
So I always do a lot of Samba.
I do a lot of fo-ho, sometimes
I'll play a little [foreign word
spoken], I'll play
the songs from my CD,
which are mostly
originals, and different,
but people really enjoy it,
so it's a blessing to be able
to perform here, and have
people appreciate the music,
and seek it out, and support.
It's just, I feel
really fortunate
that people enjoy the music.
>> Well we feel really fortunate
that you took the Archive
Challenge, accepted it, and came
and performed these
amazing field recordings
from the late 1930s,
recorded in northern Brazil,
as part of the Discotheque
Collection.
And I know that people will
enjoy for generations on,
enjoy the recordings of
your performance today.
>> Wonderful.
>> So thank you, Cissa Paz.
>> Thank you.
It's a blessing to be here.
>> September 20, 2017, and we've
just had the Archive Challenge
concert, at which we
asked a group of musicians
to learn material from the
American Folk Life Center
Archive, here at the
Library of Congress.
And one of those musicians
was the great Phil Wiggins,
who is a blues harmonica
player, and singer,
and who is a 2017 recipient
of the National Heritage
Fellowship,
from the National
Endowment for the Arts.
>> Yeah.
>> And this is Phil Wiggins.
And Phil, I gues the first
question I'll ask is how does it
feel to be an NEA
National Heritage Fellow?
>> It's just amazing.
You know, it's probably
going to take a while to come
into complete focus, but just
to be recognized like that way
in my own home, it was,
it was pretty amazing.
>> All right.
And Phil is a resident
of Tacoma Park, Maryland.
So he's from the D.C. area, and
>> Right.
>> This is his home town.
And he picked some music,
some interesting music
from the archive
to perform for us.
So why don't you tell us about
the songs that you chose.
>> Okay, well Jennifer
Cutting was very helpful to me.
She sent me some great choices
of this one particular
harmonica player,
whose name I can't
remember right now,
and who I had not
heard of before,
and so it was great
getting to know his music,
but I was more kind
of interested in kind
of doing music that didn't
already have harmonica.
So I chose two songs
that were both recorded
at Parchment Penitentiary
by Alan Lomax,
as far as I could tell,
they seemed to be
recorded 20 years apart.
So the first one was recorded in
1939, which was Charles Butler,
singing this beautiful
song, Diamond Joe,
which I had heard once before,
and fallen in love with it,
from the same recording
just well, I mean, I could,
I guess the main point
that I'm getting at is
at the time I first heard it,
I never imagined myself actually
trying to sing it in public, so,
so it was a great
opportunity for me,
because between what has
happened to me between now
and then is that my
partner, John Cephas,
of over 30 years, passed away.
And as you probably remember,
John had that beautiful baritone
voice, and so at that time,
I wasn't doing much
singing at all.
But since John has passed, I've
been doing a lot of singing.
I guess you could say I've
been getting better at it,
but at least I've been gaining
more confidence about it.
And so, so, you know,
it was a challenge,
but I really enjoyed
learning that song,
and working up the courage to
actually sing it in public.
>> And what appealed to
you about Diamond Joe,
so much, do you remember?
>> Ooh, well, it's, you know,
it's acapella, and that,
this guy Charles Butler
has a beautiful voice.
Someone today described him
and said it's like right almost
on the edge of yodeling
some of the time.
And it's a beautiful melody.
It's, you know, it's
not a simple melody.
I mean, you know,
when you listen to it,
at first it sounds simple,
but he is doing some pretty
cool things with the melody.
There's a couple times where you
think he's going to hit a note,
then he hits the
note a half step flat
from what you thought
he was going to hit,
and so it's got some
nice surprises in it,
and it's just beautiful.
Well, the recording is
interesting, because you know,
he's performing it at
Parchment Penitentiary.
And you can hear Alan Lomax's
voice in the background,
and in a way, he's kind of
shouting at him, you know?
I mean it doesn't, it
doesn't sound like you know,
I guess it seems almost to
me like he's talking to him
in a way that he thinks he's
used to being spoken to in
that setting, it's not--
it's not, doesn't seem that
respectful or anything to me,
it's kind of distracting
in a way--
>> Yeah, I'll say
one thing about that.
I think if I'm not mistaken,
that's actually the recording
was actually made by John Lomax,
who was Alan's father.
>> John-- that's
what I, I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, and John had a way of
speaking that sounded that way.
I'm sure he didn't mean
it to sound that way,
but I know what you
mean, when you talk
about that tone of voice.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. But yeah, it was pretty
amazing, I mean, you know,
you immediately feel that it's a
very different time, than when,
than we are living in now.
And I mean, you know, it's, it's
amazing that he captured that.
And of course, you know, so
there's no harmonica in it,
and the song has this
great verse that is just
like custom made to intro a
harmonica solo, says I'm going
up on the mountain,
give my horn a blow,
thought I heard my Maybelle
say yonder comes my bow--
you know, right after that,
there should be harmonica.
>> Definitely.
>> So that's what
I took, you know,
because there's no other
instruments in it, but...and,
and it was surprising to me.
There were notes that
he sang that I wished,
that I was wishing laid
in a different place
on the harmonica, where I
could really lean into them
and bend them and all,
but they kind of--
you know, worked against me.
Which was cool, because you
know, I wasn't able just
to do my normal hot
dogging, you know,
my own normal comfort
zone, I had to just--
take those notes where I found
them, and figure out a way
to get the most expression out
of them, which was a challenge.
But, I mean it made me play
completely differently,
and it made the end
result something different
than what I thought I wanted
at the beginning, but you know,
in the end, you know, I
liked, I liked the challenge.
And I liked where,
where it took me.
>> Mm-hmm.
Well, we loved it as well.
And I'll tell everyone
who is watching this video
that you can see Phil's
performance on the Library
of Congress website,
in the Lomax--
or the Archive Challenge
concert video.
And the original performance,
actually is on our website
as well, in the John and
Ruby Lomax collection,
The Southern Mosaic,
it's called.
So you can search for that
as well, on our website.
You can hear both Phil and the
source recording that he used.
So that's a great story.
So what about the second
one, which was years later,
but also at Parchment, right?
>> Yeah, true.
True. And that's-- it's just
kind of a funny coincidence,
but the second one is one that
I was pretty familiar with.
I was surprised to find
the recording there.
The performance, the person
performing it there was John
Dudley, who was, you know, I
guess serving time at Parchment.
His version of that song
seems to be from here
and the Tommy Johnson
Big Road Blues, you know,
and it's got this great like
driving line, that for like,
about the first 8 bars
is real syncopated,
and then switches
kind of to a loping,
more of a steady loping beat,
and it's so distinctive,
and it just makes you
want to get off your butt,
and just like, and you
know, I've been aware
of that song for a long time.
So it was great to find
that version of it,
and then there are some other
songs where people just like,
just like John Dudley did,
heard Tommy Johnson's version,
and then took from
that, you know,
and made their own version.
There's a version of it that
I kind of blended into that,
called Stop and Listen, that is
done by the Mississippi Sheikhs,
and it's that same groove, but
it's completely different words.
And you know, they're
really great,
really good lyrics,
and so I like that.
So I mixed the two.
And also mixed in
there is a little bit
of Smokestack Lightning, the
Howlin' Wolf song, so you know,
it's all you know, it's, I
mean it's interesting to me
because I'm aware that
there are some people
that take those Lomax recordings
and that are basically,
you know, frozen in
time, and they just try
to recreate them note for
note, but those, those people
that they recorded,
you know if you record
with them the next day you
would have gotten something
completely different.
>> And sometimes Alan did that.
Yeah.
>> Yeah, and so to me, it's
that, that's the tradition
that I want to follow.
Is to you know, just take the
influences, do my own thing
with them, improvise with them,
and come up with something,
you know, that's living,
that's not you know,
like frozen in time,
or carbon copy of--
like I said today when
I was doing Diamond Joe,
I said basically "I don't
know what's about to happen,
so there might be a little
bit of Bessie Jones mixed
in with the Charles Butler,"
and that turned out to be true.
>> Right.
>> I didn't know if I was going
to be able to pull it off,
but I mean, that to me is
what I love about music.
Is the improvisation,
the spontaneity of it.
You know?
>> And how did you decide
to add a piano to that one?
>> You know, that, that bass
line that I'm talking about,
I mean, you just-- I mean
to me, because I love piano,
piano is probably about
my favorite instrument.
I grew up, you know, my
parents loved piano music,
most of the records they
collected were piano,
and that syncopated bass line,
I think probably Tommy Johnson
and whoever else, I think
they were mimicking piano.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> On that, you know,
so I just heard piano.
And so because I mean I had a
choice, I could have brought,
you know, a guitar player, but I
wanted that piece done on piano,
because it lays so
nice on the piano,
and I just think that's
the way it was meant to be.
>> Yeah. Sounds great, yeah.
And I think, you know,
you really touched
on something important there,
which is that these guys,
in 1959, and even in 1939,
were already listening
to commercial recordings, so
they, they were being influenced
by more than one thing--
>> Right, yes.
>> When they played
it, and the people
who originally recorded it
were probably influenced
by piano players they heard,
and other people, so to keep it,
you know, as you say, frozen
in time, just doesn't--
doesn't really continue the
tradition in the same way
that the tradition was
going back then I think.
>> Yeah, yeah.
And like that song Diamond Joe,
I don't-- I couldn't really,
or I haven't yet found out where
Bessie Jones got her version
of it, but I could tell
that Charles Butler, I mean,
it was just a couple
of tiny little things,
almost like incidental, like you
could miss them, but that kind
of clued me in that he
definitely had heard the version
of it that she's singing.
So--
>> Yeah, so those
influences are always there.
>> Yeah.
>> Well thank you so much
for playing in the concert,
we really enjoyed having you.
And it is an honor to have
a National Heritage Fellow
[chuckling] on our stage always.
>> Well thank you.
>> And it's an honor
to have you,
even before you were a
National Heritage Fellow,
we had you several times,
and I was an honor then too.
So.
>> Well it's always a pleasure
to be here, I was just,
you know, and as soon
as I get a chance,
I'm going to go get my Library
of Congress Library Card
renewed, I think it's--
>> Please do, and come see
us in the Reading Room,
we'll find you more great stuff.
>> All right, great.
Thank you.
>> September 20, 2017,
and we just had the American
Folk Life Center Archive
Challenge Concert in
the Coolidge Auditorium,
here at the Library of Congress.
And for that concert, we asked
five different individuals
or groups to record songs that
they learned from our archive.
And one of the artists
that we asked
to do that was Dom Flemons.
And I'm here with Don
Flemons now, and we are going
to have a little conversation
about the songs that he played.
But the first question I'll ask
you is, Dom, since you've been
at the Library, since the last
time you played here, I think,
you've started to
perform under the rubric
of The American Songster.
So why don't you tell us a
little bit about the name,
the American Songster, and
the Songster tradition.
>> Well, of course.
Thank you so much for
having me, Steven,
and well the American Songster,
well first, that was actually--
I'd named one of my albums,
just American Songster.
And what got me to do that was,
well, specifically it was one
of the artists whose tune
I performed, Lead Belly.
When I started studying the
music of not just Lead Belly,
but people like Mance
Lipscomb, and a couple
of the other performers, they
are under the umbrella term
of like, blues singers,
most of the time.
But as I started reading
more about these musicians,
they were known as
songsters, and songsters were--
first they were like books of
song lyrics in the 19th Century,
and then the 20th Century,
a lot of different musicians
that could play and sing
a lot of different types
of numbers they became
songsters, like the book.
So it was kind of
like a human jukebox.
And as, well, you know, as
a musician that has come
up in the time as the
20th Century ends,
and the 21st Century started,
the full consciousness
of that people are into a lot
of different types of music,
that's something I've always
tried to emphasize in my work,
just because I'm not just a
blues singer, or folk singer,
or country singer, I play
a little bit of it all.
I love the term songster,
because it was just something
people hadn't heard before,
but it was actually
something a lot older.
So it was really cool to have
that juxtaposition of both new
and old at the same time,
and then American, of course,
is that's where I'm
from, you know,
and to really emphasize
American identity with songster,
and being able to bring all
these different ideas together,
it was appealing to me.
So when I broke away
from my previous group,
the Carolina Chocolate Drops,
I wanted to figure out how
to put a bigger idea out there,
instead of just saying hey,
I'm Don Flemons,
all right, you know,
I wanted to have a bigger idea.
So The American Songster
ended up being something
that people could latch
onto that term, or my name,
and it just gave something
a little bit bigger
than just myself.
I'm trying to represent
a larger tradition.
>> Mm-hmm, and you've recorded,
you're one of the few artists
in the concert who
recorded material
from our archives before,
so in this case, you were--
you sort of were
on familiar ground.
And the first song you
chose was Poor Howard.
So explain a little bit about
that, and how you found it.
>> Well, Poor Howard is
an interesting number
in the way that, you know,
the first time I
actually heard it was
on the great three-record
set that Electra Records put
out of Lead Belly, of the
Library of Congress recordings,
and my first introduction to
Lead Belly's music, you know,
was when I got into Bob
Dylan's music, and his song,
Song for Woody, mentions,
you know, Cisco,
and Sonny, and Lead Belly too.
So you know, being this sort
of inquisitive person I am,
I decided to figure out
who these guys were.
And of course that led me
to Smithsonian Folk Ways,
and then Lead Belly, I
always like to describe him
as like the Rosetta Stone of
African American folk music,
just because, especially
since I was, you know,
born in the late
20th Century, of,
most African American folk
music, a lot of it is blues,
and jazz, and spiritual music,
church music of different types,
and Lead Belly just represented
this sort of bigger idea.
Just like the Rosetta Stone,
to this sort of ancient world
of music, and also
that he recorded
so many different versions
and different types of songs,
that it really let me be
able to delve into, you know,
just not just a bunch of
different types of material,
but Lead Belly also
performed many of the songs,
different tempos,
different styles,
and just different
ways of doing it.
And so Poor Howard, there is
this one particular version
that he did, that Larry Cohen
compiled for the Electra set,
that just really blew me away.
And it's all a section on
the record that is listed
as Sookie Jumps, which was kind
of square dance music
for Lead Belly.
And it featured that song,
and well as Gonna Dig a
Hole to Put the Devil In.
And I thought that those two
songs would go really great
as a medley together.
So I decided to put
Poor Howard together,
and of course the story
that he told, Alan Lomax,
he said that Poor Howard was
the first negro fiddler from,
that was freed from
slavery and that was
like his main theme song.
It was Poor Howard.
So I thought that was
great, and the idea
of being Poor Howard is dead
and gone, he left me here
to sing this song, and
as the American Songster,
I can kind of make it
reflective, so that you know,
because in my shows, when I play
it, I can tell people, you know,
this is a song that really
symbolizes what I try to do.
Because I try to get the
impression, the emotion,
maybe the rhythm, the
whatever it might be.
The raw essence of what that
original field recording had,
and be able to present it
in a way that is both--
it both emphasizes what I do as
a musician personally as well
as what that original
recording put out there.
Because you know, when I started
studying Alan Lomax's material,
especially after working
with the Library of Congress,
talking about, you know,
coriemetrics [phonetic spelling]
and cancer metrics, and
all that, he talks a lot
about how they are sort of like,
they're nuances there, right?
Below the surface that really
they resonate with people,
so when you see certain
nuances or subtleties to music,
you can relate to them,
especially if you're familiar
with it, like if you hear
a blues song, and they hit
that blues lick in
the right way,
you can just say
that's it, that's it.
So I've always just tried
to have that in my music,
and so Poor Howard is
a great one for that.
And Wanna Dig a Hole
to Put the Devil
In is just a great little
fun square dance number.
So I wanted to have
both those together.
And I also wanted to
reference Pete Seeger as well.
Because Pete was really
close with Lead Belly
and Lead Belly really
helped Pete get
on the trajectory that he did.
And the idea of the banjo being
an African derived instrument,
and also it being, there's
a proverb called Sankofa
and the banjo does that,
it brings the past
into the present.
And that's something that Pete
did as well with his music,
bringing the past
into the present,
creating a new wave
for the future.
So that was what I was
thinking about with that one.
And yeah, it's one I've
been able to say I'm proud
to say I was able to take
to the Kennedy Center,
with the Lead Belly at 125, that
was a big thing, and being able
to take it to Carnegie Hall,
when they did the Lead
Belly tribute concert.
That was something as well.
So on top of what I learned
with that original recording,
being able to take it into
my own personal repertoire.
I've then been able
to take it out there
and show people what this
music is all about too.
>> All right.
Yeah, and Lead Belly of
course was a songster
in the same sense,
and the song is
about being a songster
[laughter],
so it's very much
reflective of what you do,
and sort of a perfect
fit for your repertoire.
So we are really glad that
you brought that one for us.
The other song that you sang
is related to some extent
to a project that you're working
on now, about cowboy songs.
So tell us a little bit
about how you got interested
in cowboy songs in
the first place?
>> Oh yeah.
Well, you know, I'm originally
from Phoenix, Arizona,
so cowboy songs, and
cowboy culture is something
that I've just known about ever
since I've gotten into music,
even before I played
guitar, like cowboy poetry
and cowboy songs, it's something
that I was interested in.
I mentioned I was into Bob
Dylan, that easily gets you
to Rambling Jack Elliott,
so he was also a
conduit to get in there.
Also you know, in my college,
at Northern Arizona University,
they had all of the Library of
Congress records, all the LPs,
and so I first heard Goodbye
Old Paint on the cowboy songs,
ballads, and cattle, you
know, cattle calls from Texas.
That's that great record
there, so I was interested
in cowboy music, and also
the New World Records album,
Back in the Saddle, which is a
great anthology of cowboy stuff,
so I never played much
cowboy music at first,
but it was an idea that
was interesting to me,
because my family has
roots deep in Arizona.
My dad is from Flagstaff,
Arizona, and then his father was
from East Texas, then came over
to Flagstaff in the early 1950s,
and then he started his
church, Church of God
in Christ in Holbrook, Arizona.
So he was called by
God to go to Holbrook,
which I then studied
Holbrook is one
of the baddest towns
in the west.
And it was also the first
place where cattle were brought
into Arizona via the train.
And so there were a lot of
just interesting little stories
that were wrapped up, so
my own personal interest
in black cowboys, when I
first saw that was a piece
of the puzzle, you know, even
though you don't see them a lot
in book and movies, the African
American culture has purveyed
in the west for a long time,
even before the southwest was
part of the United States,
and it was a part of Mexico,
there is a big history
deep within that, then.
So the album just started
expanding into this bigger idea.
I was traveling on I-40 from
North Carolina, where I lived
for a lot of years, to go
visit family and I came
across a book called The Negro
Cowboys, by Phillip Dunham,
and it was a really-- just
started expanding my idea
of what, how big this
story of black cowboys was.
Also the Lomax's did some
wonderful field recordings
of you know, people like, I
don't know, Big Charlie Butler,
who did Diamond Joe like
Phil Wiggins did earlier
in the concert, and then
also there were people
like Pete Harris, who had
a style that was similar
to another musician who recorded
in the 1920s, Henry
Ragtime Texas.
>> Right.
>> Thomas.
And so there was just sort
of like a lot of material
and a lot of stylistic things.
Then, of course, the cornerstone
for my project Black
Cowboys is Goodbye Old Pain,
and Jess Morris' story about
how these black cowboys
that he met early on in
his life taught him how
to play Goodbye Old Paint,
and also taught him how
to play the fiddle too,
and that was something
that was really a part
of his musical education,
and of course, that's
something that I've talked
with a lot in my career.
Talking about how you
have these situations,
where you have performers
that are not African American.
They will take the
music a certain place,
and it will become very popular,
but by their own admission,
the roots of their music has
kind of a cultural interchange
within it, and of
course, that's something
that we all know
on a ground level.
People love music, and they all
get together because of that.
But with the cowboy story,
that's hadn't been something
that had been talked about in
an album form, and so I wanted
to try to just, I don't know,
fill the gap in that way.
>> I mean I think it's
similar with country music too,
that A.P. Carter learned so
much from African American folks
as well, and it kind of
got erased from the history
for a while, but people like
Mike Seeger, and yourself,
are you know, bringing
that history back.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah, so it's great.
So how did you decide to do
Goodbye Old Paint on the banjo?
Oh-- I'm sorry, you
did that on the guitar.
Yeah.
>> Well funny enough,
with Goodbye Old Paint,
that is something that has
to do with keys, you know?
Like at first of
course, I had the song,
and I knew that I wanted
it to be a part of it,
so then I went back to
the field recording.
And I started listening
back to it.
And I realized that it
was in the key of E flat,
when I listened to it.
And E flat happens to
be a key that I can--
it's kind of like the top of
my range, so I can kind of do
like a-- kind of
like a bluegrass sort
of yell with-- in E flat.
So when I heard that,
I said, great!
It will be in E flat.
And Jess Morris has--
it's a really loopy little
tune that he records.
And it's different
every verse [chuckling].
So I had to, I just
straightened it out in that way.
And you know, when starting
to play it on the guitar,
I ran into a wonderful fellow
at the National Cowboy Poetry
Gathering, named Don Edwards,
and he's just a-- I mean,
he's just a phenomenal player,
great singer, of
all different types,
and he was very much
someone who helped me think
about how I wanted to
craft this whole project,
because he's very multi-faceted
with how he handles cowboy music
as well, but we got to
talking about black cowboys.
And for him, he was
telling me how, you know,
a lot of times a scholarship
around cowboy music tends
to be focused on
the British Isles,
and the ballad traditions, which
is a very strong part of it,
but he also mentioned
that several of the songs
that he heard had kind of a
sense of the blues, almost like,
kind of a song going down
the road feeling bad.
Not really like blues as we
think of blues, blues, 12 bars,
but kind of just, had a bit of
that feeling, and that sort of,
sort of structure, melodically
that would really be emphasized
with the blues later, and so
the conversation he and I had
about it, it just got me
thinking, okay well if I think
about Jess Morris learning
from this black cowboy,
how might he have sung it
if he had just a tonality
of the blues, that's
not quite the blues,
but it has a little
bit of that tone.
So Goodbye Old Paint happens
to be a great number for,
because in string band music,
you have the same thing,
where there's not a
lot of chord changes,
but you can bend little notes
up and down, and create a lot
of really nice give and
take, and a lot of suspense,
with just what would be
a very monotone song.
And so Goodbye Old
Paint, I thought,
was just a wonderful one
to be able to do that,
stretch a couple notes up,
have a couple of short notes,
and be able to tell a
very interesting story.
Because it's like I still--
it still surprises me
when I'm performing it,
how emotional the song is.
Because it's-- it's very
simple words to it, you know,
but when you get about three
or four verses into it,
all of a sudden, it's
like a movie that plays
out in your mind, and it's a
very beautiful song in that way.
And that's where it has that
really great juxtaposition
of what would become the blues,
but also the same qualities
that narrative ballads,
and you know,
the British Isles
traditions have.
So it's kind of a really
nice mixture of both.
>> Yeah, yeah, you really get a
sense of the reluctance to leave
through him saying
"I'm leaving,"
so many times, but not leaving.
You know, things are-- he says
what's in his hand, he's all set
to leave, but he doesn't
leave for a long time.
And you can feel that
emotion in there.
>> Well you know, that's a big
part of the theme that I found
when I started delving into the
black cowboy story is you had
this sense of movement.
Because you know, one of
the things that, you know,
like a lot of times, we
think of the United States
as being the whole land
mass, but before the 1840s,
it went pretty much out
to Tennessee, then it went
up to the Ohio River, and then
slowly it steadily started
having, you know, the land mass
in the states begin
to move west.
One of the things that happened,
especially with African
American culture,
is that each time they
added a new state,
they'd have to decide
whether it was going
to be pro-slavery
or anti-slavery.
>> Yeah.
>> Then even Texas, for a long
time, before the Civil War,
really you know, started really
going into full force, you know,
you had plantation owners,
they would take their slaves
and bring them to Texas, because
it was literally outside the
borders of the United States.
>> Right.
>> but because of all
these different things,
it led to this huge
African American population,
and you know, again you have
things like Catholicism,
as well, that was a big
part of the Mexican hat,
and you had this mixture
of cultures that happened,
and this, right again,
right below the surface,
and the black cowboy
story is wrapped up in all
of these things, but you know,
Goodbye Old Paint kind of has
that feel, because you know,
going from Cheyenne, Wyoming,
you know, that was all
the way from Texas,
and they'd go all the way
up to Abilene, Kansas,
to get the cattle, to the
train, because at first Abilene,
Kansas was the one
place you could have,
you had the cattle
going on the train.
>> You had the rail, yeah.
>> So this idea that you had
to keep moving in spite of all
of it is just something that is
a big part of cowboy culture,
then also of course African
American culture, with cowboys.
So Goodbye Old Paint really
grabs all of those themes,
and again, in a very subtle way,
which is again, what makes it,
you know, probably why it's one
of the most well-known cowboy
songs, and then of course,
that's part of the
joy in performing it.
>> Right. Well thanks so much
for taking the Archive
Challenge,
and we should tell the viewers
that you can actually
watch this concert,
it's called The American Folk
Life Center Archive Challenge
Concert, and it's online at the
Library of Congress website.
Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.